murder ball was uh  these this uh sport for  like para athletes like uh paraplegics  yeah like um paralyzed guys and this one  guy was hanging out with partying  and and uh he's like oh dude can you  help me with my catheter  right he's all hammered he's got to pee  and i'm like all right you know i'm a  bro  and i i grabbed his wiener i put the  catheter  really yeah that's nice of you yeah and  i was like hey dude no big deal man  i'm cool like that i'm very secure with  myself so  how do you get a catheter in there i  would it like you kind of have to  hold it and like i mean spit on it shut  up you got to get it you gotta drink it  yeah get it hard  i can't remember it i i it was a long  long long time ago  damn but these guys are i'm a little i'm  a little concerned about that because  they do have use of their arms they're  playing  why would he need help he's  a quadriplegic that's a good question  i don't know that's [ __ ] hilarious  dude  yeah dude